[Applause]
doing good is increasingly about more
than giving away money I have a spare
kidney why not share it a new movement
is driving people to choose altruistic
careers we're just seeing a general
upswing in care about ethical career
choice and altruists are looking further
than ever before
into the future we're trying to make
sure you ran it to survives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Katie Acosta is about to go under the
knife people either think I'm kind of
completely nuts or some feint of a human
being thank you
she's giving away one of her kidneys I
[Music]
have a fair kidney why not share it but
Katie isn't giving her organ to a friend
or family member but to save the life of
a complete stranger she's in good hands
I will be what's called a non-directed
donor so I'm giving to somebody that I
don't know who they are yet it's a
possibility that I'll never meet them
most kidney donations in America come
from people who have just died but katie
is part of a rising altruistic trend the
number of living kidney donors has
increased by 16 percent since 2014 and
from 2017 to 2018 donations to complete
strangers rose by 31 percent it's just a
feeling of purpose this idea that
something I'm doing could have such a
big impact on someone else's life but
for living donors like Katy saving a
stranger's life is not without risks
nearly 1 in 3,000 people die from the
procedure so that's the kidney right
there that's the one he's gonna be
taking out
[Music]
we will prepare the kidney for
transplant this will most certainly
either save someone's life or increase
their quality of life sort of
exponentially and the cost at least to
me is nothing when you think about you
know the kind of effect it can have on
someone's life
like Kati an increasing number of young
people in Britain say they want to lead
more altruistic lives
[Music]
research suggests that almost two-thirds
of British Millennials want to work for
a company that makes a positive
difference we're just seeing a general
upswing in care about ethical career
choice
this Oxford University professor
co-founded 80,000 hours a charity that
gives career advice to altruistically
minded people as part of the effective
altruism movement that takes a
scientific approach to calculating ways
of doing good and an old-fashioned
career advice was this idea of just you
should follow your passion you figured
out what cause you really care about and
then go and work in that sector where
there's I think the most important thing
is to figure out what problems are most
important and then secondly what does
that cause need increasingly the charity
is suggesting careers in new fields such
as AI and synthetic biology that is
shaping the world's future some of the
areas like novel technologies much more
in need of just very talented and
sensible and altruistic people and so
what we tend to recommend is people
going into policy careers often research
careers and often working directly and
nonprofits in some of these and key
cores areas
so far the charity says it has helped
3,000 people make major changes in their
career plans affecting 80 million hours
of work time the effective altruism
movement also encourages people to give
away a minimum of 10 percent of the
money they earn now I've made the
decision to donate most of my income
over the course of my life in fact
everything above 25 thousand pounds per
year after tax over 4,000 people have
signed up to Professor McCaskill's
initiative giving what we can and so far
over 126 million dollars has been
donated it's just becoming much more
than norm that people think yes everyone
on this planet is equal in the model
worth
this thinking is leading some in the
effective altruism movement towards a
new focus the lives of people who will
be born in the centuries to come we need
to save humanity yes
end of story funded by wealthy
philanthropists these scientists are
researching threats to the survival of
the human race we are trying to look at
risks and problems that may be facing us
now that may have a long-term effect on
the far turn future this team at Oxford
University's future of humanity
Institute works in an area known as
existential risk they identify dangers
both natural and man-made that could
wipe out humankind altogether I work
with mathematical models to look at
pandemic risk that could be a threat to
our species and try to decide on
different countermeasures how would we
prevent deliberate biological events
from occurring how would we deal with
pandemics that might be much larger than
something we've ever prepared for these
scientists argue that altruism could be
most effective when focused on the value
of human life in the far future so why
should we care about people who might
live in a thousand years time just as we
shouldn't be discriminating as people
who are physically far away in space
from us we shouldn't discriminate
against people who happen to be far away
in time the future human population
Dwarfs the current population enormously
if we look around us the world is valued
but it was valuable yesterday and it
will be valuable tomorrow so we better
make sure tomorrow comes
you